going to be max freed who didn't throw a
lot down the stretch due to a couple of
injury issues declared fit and ready for
this one after a perfectly unblemished
7-0 regular season now the pitch to
castiano's breaking ball and he sends
one of the air to short center field
that'll fall for a hit since elle makes
the turn at second stumbles on his way
to third but still dives in safely
wow what a start here the first two
batters of the ball game already jumping
on the braves ace max freed falling to
strike to mike mastakas lefty lefty
matchup pitch on the way chopper to
second ozzie's on the other end he'll
fling it over to first base there's out
number three and max indeed weaves in
and out of traffic in the top of the
first inning on the mound for the reds
today a 2018 all-star himself and
likely the front runner for national
excite young honors trevor bauer
freddie freeman jumps on the first pitch
drives one deep to right backing up
castellanos and he makes the catch just
in front of the wall
wow
a fine running grab by castellanos
back to work on duval to 1-2 and a
curveball takes care of him the first
strike out of the day for trevor bauer
he has got a good one
back home with a 2-2 pit just wants it
swinging to miss struck him out with a
breaking ball swanson swings right
through it
you can strut off the mound when you're
that good
bauer back to the plate strength recall
fastball right over the outside corner
and that is three consecutive punch out
here's your breaking ball
got him on it
how'd you know that
no seriously
was that just a straight guess no
sally sets away pitch fastball strike
[Music]
and five consecutive punch outs by
trevor bauer
hitters count here for the cincinnati
third baseman and he hits a high fly
ball to deep left field duvall at the
warning track and he will make the catch
in front of the wall
a lot of contact for the reds only one
strikeout there's a slow poke out
towards freddy and he has got it for the
out
oh he got a call on it to strike out
ozuna
[Music]
and a called strike three taken by
duvall
bauer strands a pair
he hits the hole on the left side
castellanos is going to wrap around and
try for third throw there is in time to
get him
a gutsy decision to try to get to third
on a base hit to left oh and two to
suarez
throws him on the breaking ball five
strikeouts for free
oh that one's sent into center field and
well hit it's going to chase senzel
atlanta has its first extra base hit of
the game
[Music]
got him swinging
trevor bauer strands a lead off double
to keep it scoreless in atlanta
first pitch misses high and now they've
gotten a rundown kyle farmer
[Applause]
[Applause]
can cross the plate
austin reilly sold out and dove
barnhart sets away
and a check swing this time in the dirt
and duvall could not check in time
that's the third strikeout for adam
duvall here in this bowl game
queen gonna miss and he strikes out
swanson seven scoreless innings in the
book 11 strikeouts for trevor bauer
the 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss he blew fastball by him
right there for his 12th strikeout david
bell is going to go get the ball from
his starter handshakes all around for
trevor bauer after a masterful
appearance here in game one of the
national league wildcard series winning
run support to start the last of the
night so now marcelo zuna
swinging a miss
99 mile an hour fastball and delivers
strike three called right over the
outside corner
and all these strikes out
the dominant night by reichsel iglesias
got him
for smith after a bunch of sliders
couldn't lay off at that time
back-to-back strikeouts for smith and
now the braves can potentially win it
with a base hit as austin reilly will be
the batter
swinging a miss by riley
sims pitches out of it stranding the
winning run at second
and there's ball four that's going to
load the bases with two away then mike
mustack is hitless this afternoon
and matsik defuses a bomb in the top of
the 11th inning and they leave them
loaded this is on the verge of becoming
the first game in postseason history to
be scoreless through 11 innings
and that's exactly what this game has
done go ahead run is 90 feet away 3-2
jankowski runs again and barnhart
strikes out
got him looking
a wild pitch advances the winning run at
a scoring position now full two
and we are going to the 13th for the
second straight inning the reds have
loaded the bases
broke his back grounded his shortstop
and the braves get out of it
graves had the winning rod at third base
and the braves have won it
who else but freddie freeman to deliver
the walk-off blow
[Music]